it's in the kid probably he's got a
outstanding podcast and Ben welcome back
hey how are you Ben first off the number
one story in America even though it
should be about the State of the Union
is about the intrigue beyond this Devon
Nunez release he evidently our revised
at the request of the FBI some portions
of the memo causing atom shift the
ranking member on the Intelligence
Committee to say we have to revote on
this or which should not be released at
all I doubled down on that what is
interesting to you about this debate I
mean the only thing that's interesting
to me about the debate is the
obfuscation of the actual underlying
material I've been calling for the
declassification of as much of this as
possible because we just don't know who
to trust either somebody's lying or
everybody's lying right either they're
Nunez is exaggerating the malfeasance at
the FBI or the FBI is fibbing about its
own malfeasance or everybody is
exaggerating everywhere we're not gonna
know that until not only we see the
underlying memo but we also see the
underlying classified information as
much as is available for release because
we don't know who to trust in LA a lot
of this at the hands of the Obama
administration it's pretty clear at this
point that the Obama administration was
impeding the Hillary Clinton
investigation with the help of the FBI
or at least players within the FBI and
we don't know to what extent the FBI was
involved in some sort of nefarious
activity with regard to the Trump
campaign or whether they were actually
doing their job we're not gonna know any
of that until we actually see this stuff
so right now it's a lot of speculation
and a lot of innuendo about stuff the
American people haven't seen and that's
forcing people to choose between
narrative storylines for which they have
no evidence to support and it sounds
like there's a possibility we could
actually see it later on today the
Republicans would like to get it out and
so with the president United States and
John Kelly told Brian yesterday that
it's gonna be out very very shortly but
let me ask you this why is the
Department of Justice and the FBI
they're both going to the White House
and you can't you can't run this thing
they're they're hitting a the panic
button on it do you buy into the whole
deep state thing or is it something else
I mean I don't know the answer to that
and again I don't think we're going to
know the answer until this stuff is
Declassified because sure it's possible
that there's some sort of national
security risk in revealing how FISA
memos were were gathered or how fives
warrants were gathered rather but we
don't know that until
we actually know that so the question is
the FBI's basically saying trust us
right the DOJ is saying trust us you
can't see this stuff but our trust in
them is the entire question here is that
the question is whether we can trust
them and we're being told by both
members of the Trump administration then
as well as Devin Nunez that they're
obviously not trustworthy so until the
American people get to see this we're
not gonna know whether this is a
Republican overplay and/or an attempt to
shut down the Muller investigation or an
attempt to to smear the FBI or whether
this is the FBI attempting to protect
itself from its own malfeasance the only
thing I would say is about Mo of
Muller's here and this is here and as
Speaker Ryan said without looking and
and trey gowdy as well we're not looking
to stop mower investigation this is
something different
yep I mean I then I think that's the key
distinction that Republicans ought to be
making they ought to be saying listen we
can look it's our job I mean we are an
oversight body it's our job to oversee
an institution that we created and so
it's our job to look into what the FBI
did with regard to the Hillary
investigation we're not trying to shut
down the Muller investigation if they
make that clear it looks a lot less
politically politically motivated I
think okay